[Music]
well it doesn't happen that much
when everyone in washington agrees with
one another on something
but when it does when democrats
republicans and the media
all sound alike all sing the same song
from the same hymnal when nancy pelosi
talks about venezuelan coups like the
neocon she actually is
you ought to be nervous about that
institutional washington
is by far at its most dangerous when
there's consensus when it stops
reflecting the will of the voters
and starts defending its own interests
without any opposition whatsoever
there may be no issue that unites the
establishment wings of both political
parties
other than fighting pointless wars more
than this issue and it's here it is
leaking classified information that
hurts the permanent political class
is a grave threat to national security
it must be stamped out but
leaking classified information that
helps the permanent political class
is an act of good faith son you're
getting a pulitzer for that
so there was no problem when the fbi
told the washington post that
that diabolical vladimir putin was
secretly running our government that was
a lie but not a problem
or when the cia director gave classified
information to the producers of zero
dark 30 because that's hollywood and
they're our friends
but when those leagues implicate the
people in charge
oh it's a national crisis and someone
needs to go to jail
and often people do go to jail julian
assange for example he's rotting away in
a prison in london right now why
he published information the us
government wanted to keep secret not to
protect dust but to protect themselves
footage of an american helicopter
gunning down 18 people in iraq including
by the way two journalists from reuters
he also publicized emails exposing
corruption at the very highest levels of
the dnc
bernie sanders voters may have been
grateful for that they got completely
shafted and wouldn't have known it
now they do and that infuriated the
people who run washington
just to be clear julian assange did not
hack servers at the us army depending on
the dnc
no he reported on those servers that's
called
journalism which by the way real
journalism not much left
it's all under attack trust us so for
doing that
for humiliating both our elected leaders
and the media class julian assange's
life has been destroyed
he's been locked away for almost a
decade this case is not about espionage
he didn't commit espionage
he's not a traitor he's not american
this case is about criminalizing
freedom of speech the mother of julian
assange's children
came on this show last year and made
that point very succinctly watch
julian's is the foremost perhaps the
foremost
free speech campaigner uh alive
in the west and he's imprisoned and does
the president
president want that to be his legacy or
does he want to
you know ensure that the first amendment
survives this trial
and survives by you know
pardoning him and not having this trial
no one who works on this show ever
imagined we'd be where we are now which
is in effect defending julian assange
but the truth is we're not defending
julian assange we're defending something
that is actually under attack that is
actually precious to every american and
that is going away faster than we ever
thought it could
and that's the freedom of speech he
reported things they don't like
they threw him in jail if it happened to
him why couldn't it happen to you again
speak slowly so we can understand
and if that doesn't convince you
consider the case of another person
we've also had on the show quite a bit a
very decent man by the way called john
kirikou
he's a 15-year veteran of the cia he led
some of the military's most important
raids in pakistan during his career
risked his life for the country
but then in 2007 he did something that
destroyed his life
he confirmed something on the record
that no one else in government was
willing to admit at the time that the us
army was in fact
waterboarding torturing prisoners now
you may support that or you may not
but if you're an american citizen who
pays for all this stuff why don't you
have a right to know that
now the doj at the time did not think
john carrick had committed a crime what
he said was true he was treated as a
whistleblower which he was
agree with him or not but five years
later the cia
which was still furious about it told
the obama administration which is in the
habit of obeying the ca to reopen that
case and punish john karaku so they did
and of course they found a crime
it's not hard for prosecutors to find a
crime when they're bent on retribution
meant to encourage the others
so john karaku went to prison for two
years
he can no longer to this day a man who
served his country for 15 years
defend his family with a firearm because
he's a convicted felon they'll give his
voting rights back but not the right to
defend
his family so here's why we're telling
you this the president
on his last day in office is expected to
announce a series of pardons before he
leaves on wednesday
some news reports tell us that he will
pardon the rapper lil wayne
on a firearm charge we don't know if
that's true or not we don't even have an
opinion on that
but we do know if he wants a lasting
historical effect on this country in the
closing days of his administration
he can achieve a major victory for the
principles
that this country was founded on and
that make it a good place to live
and the first one of those is freedom of
the press freedom of speech
no one else the media feels like arguing
for it it doesn't matter it's still true
and we should still defend it and he
should pardon julian assange and should
pardon john caracou
pamela anderson is an actress she's also
pretty well first very well versed on
this subject she's been in close contact
with julian assange and we thought we'd
like to hear from her tonight
pamela anderson thank you for coming on
why should the president pardon
julian assange well i well like he said
it says freedom of the press freedom of
speech if we don't have that we don't
have a
democracy and i really thank you for
what you're saying
and um and and i think like you said
this is a defining moment for the
president
this says the entire world wants him to
pardon or most the world wants him to
pardon julian assange
this would mean this is why he's
president this is i think the defining
moment this is this time to shine to
really
um make an impression on the world that
this was um
freedom of speech because if this goes
to trial that's the end of the first
amendment
and i just think that this is so serious
and so
important that he needs to that pardon
is sitting on his desk and i'm sure
there is a lot going on behind the
scenes where people are maybe um
bullying him a little bit because you
know there's there's an impeachment and
there's a
couple probably cranky um republican
senators
that are um negotiating with this and he
needs to do the right thing this is one
of those moments in history
in his lifetime too that he needs to
make the right decision and so it's all
up to
you know president trump but he would
really gain a huge following
and a huge um sigh of relief and
gratefulness for so many people on the
planet and
i just think that this is so important
and this is something he needs to he
needs to do
he absolutely needs to do this and i'm
just saying just just do it
you know just julian is so important to
free speech he's a free speech hero i i
think i think
the principle is worth defending and i
appreciate you're coming on site pamela
anderson thank you
thank you pardoning a little wayne
some medicare fraud criminal from
florida don't degrade yourself on the
way out don't degrade your voters
make a statement in our defense defend
the bill of rights